Hey youtubers it’s charlie and lucasfilm
is getting ready to premiere the first trailer
for the new animated show Star Wars rebels
next week so I wanted to do a video explaining
what it’s going to be about, who the characters
are and which actors are going to be in it.
If you remember last year, after Disney bought
lucasfilm for more money than you or I will
ever see in our entire lives.
They announced that they would be ending the
Clone Wars cartoon after 5 seasons.
Most people correctly assumed that this was
to make way for a new cartoon made under the
Disney umbrella.
There were all kinds of funny Mickey Mouse
Jedi and character mashups, people loved the
idea people hated the idea.
But then Lucasfilm posted a video explaining
that the same creative team behind clone wars
would be doing the new cartoon, that it would
be called Star Wars Rebels, and that it would
take place during the (quote unquote) Dark
Times.
That period after the fall of the Jedi, but
before the events of The original trilogy.
Then some concept art and and a logo showed
up.
Which you can see here.
It’s a departure from the Clone Wars style
of animation, but it looks really cool.
So I’m optimistic about the show.
And then we got news on the voice cast.
Korra fans will get super pumped because Steven
Jay Blum, the voice of Ammon will be doing
one of the characters.
They haven’t announced details on all the
characters yet, but I think we’ll learn
a lot more after that trailer comes next week.
Here’s the rest of the cast.
Freddie Prinze Jr, who everybody already knows.
David Oyelowo was in rise of the planet of
the apes and he’s in christopher nolan’s
new movie interstellar.
Vanessa Marshall who plays black widow in
Avengers Earth’s Mightiest Heroes and Taylor
Gray who’s done some other small nickelodeon
stuff.
I’m still too excited that Ammon is going
to be on star wars.
High Fives everybody, high fives for everyone.
So on the show the empire will still be hunting
down the last of the jedi, which means there
will be some jedi on the show.
But let’s take a quick poll.
Would you watch a Star Wars show knowing that
there would be no jedi?
I totally would, there are so many awesome
bounty hunters, imperial troops, rebels and
alien characters that you could do hundreds
of shows without any jedi.
But since this is the first Star Wars show
disney is making since they bought lucasfilm,
I think they’re going to play it safe and
give us some force users.
We do know that the characters will be traveling
on a ship called the Ghost.
So I’m inclined to think that none of the
voice cast they’ve announced are Jedi and
what they’ll do is just have guest characters
play jedi every once in a while as a cameo.
The ship itself is a modified corellian freighter,
so obviously they want you to think of the
millenium falcon, but it’s not the same
model.
A lot of the aspects of the Falcon are there
though.
There’s a gun turret in front and the cockpit
will look a
lot like a B23 Bomber.
It also has a lounge and crew quarters just
like the falcon.
But I would expect all of these new characters
to be original.
The show won’t premiere till Next year around
this time so we probably won’t get to see
part of or even a full episode until comic
con next year or Disney’s D23 convention.
Remember Disney didn’t do any star wars
stuff at Comic Con last year so I think they
won’t really do anything there next year
either.
They like to save all their good stuff for
their own conventions.
I’ll be doing tons of videos for this as
we learn more about the series, so be sure
to subscribe to get all those.
And let me know what you want to know most
about the show.
Do you want to know more about the characters,
more about the story, or more about the technical
details.
Like all the places they’ll be visiting
and the tech and ships they’ll be using.
As always be sure to like and share this video,
I give extra high fives to everyone that shares
my videos on social.
While we wait for that trailer to come you
can check out all my other Star Wars related
videos by clicking here and you can check
out all my legend of Korra videos my clicking
here.
Thanks again everybody, high fives!